okay so while ago a fan of mine wrote
Evan man lyrics which were to the
spider-man theme song then a few more of
my fans decide to turn that into an
actual song that we put up as a video on
my channel and now one of my fans Brian
went on the streets where he went to
meet local spider-man who were dressed
up and had them sing Evan man instead
and so I thought I'd roll the clip
because I thought it was funny and also
an amazing gesture from Brian hello I'm
Brian McCann I'm creating these videos
for Evan Carmichael heaven man Edmund
Edmund Edmund Edmund Edmund Edmund
Edmund Evan here comes Edmonds helps a
billion to entrepreneurs with whatever
they can every man every man right there
Rick Oh what happened ever man you're
thinking about every man does whatever
business mr. bacon every man any man
that's my cry like any man ever man
tried to hear hear go everywhere to it
life is a big this ain't good jicama
ever man ever man ever man that whatever
ever can spend it with suicides ever did
that big guys right now find out
whatever man
so thank you Brian thank you for
everybody who's been involved in this
Evan man series i think i think we may
be exhausted it now I think we're ready
to move on to maybe something new and
different but I wanted to put it up
because I was feeling the love that all
you guys put up I sincerely appreciate
it hope you guys have a great day and
I'll see Sir Edmund Edmund Edmund Edmund
Edmund there goes a man it just doesn't
end